- HELLO, EUROPEAN PERSON.
ARE YOU GOING TO THE STATES
FOR A HOLIDAY?
WELL, THERE'S A LOT
OF RUBBISH THERE.
LET ME TELL YOU THE COOLEST
THINGS AND PLACES TO BE.
[techno music]
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA IS COOL
FOR A CLASS TRIP,
TO BUY A BASEBALL HAT,
A BASEBALL PANT.
THEY ONLY HAVE TWO DAYS
FOR THE WEEKEND,
WHICH IS COOL, 'CAUSE
YOU PACK IN LOTS OF FUN STUFF
LIKE BEACH VOLLEYBALL
AND HAMBURGERS.
U.S. HAS, LIKE,
TOTALLY DEFINED SEXUALITIES,
AND YOU CAN TELL
WHICH IS MAN AND WHICH IS WOMAN.
LITTLE WAYNE IS A LITTLE MAN
WITH A BIG VOICE.
HE IS THE KING OF NEW ORLEANS.
ROYALTY IN THE U.S. IS PEOPLE
LIKE HULK HOGAN,
HIS DAUGHTER BROOK HOGAN,
BEN AFFLECK,
A CAT WHO CAN PLAY PIANO.
BY LAW, THE ONLY RENTAL CAR
YOU CAN GET IS A PT CRUISER.
JESUS IS, LIKE,
THE COOLEST PERSON IN THE U.S.
LIKE, HOW FRANKENSTEIN
IS THE COOLEST PERSON IN EUROPE.
THE COOLEST MUSEUMS ARE
THE M&M STORE IN TIMES SQUARE.
[techno music]